foreign
Berlin
Morocco
wonderful to meet you all
you're on wonderful Pakistan
Donna
Singapore
Mongolia
pretty interesting I think that's the
first time I've I've seen a participant
from Mongolia yeah
exciting
so
welcome everyone we're about to start
hey yeah
I mean it says everyone wants to Simply
learn thank you
um
so I'll get this
sharing going
uh participant from Mongolia yeah
exciting
so
and we also everyone we're one more
thing start before we go which is uh
okay start our live stream to LinkedIn
live
I mean it says everyone wants to Simply
got it
all right so
welcome to the program overview
um this is uh with Purdue University
simply learn as a delivery partner with
Purdue for a number of their programs
one we're talking about today uh is
business analysis and we'll give you
reasons to get certified in business
analysis this year
um the great career we'll be going over
that with Brian Campbell uh who's here
with me today and we're going to be
asking some questions about you along
the way and polls uh if you're in the
streaming service please put your
answers for those polls a b c d chat but
also um q a if you have questions you
want to ask
uh Brian and me toward the end of the
session we'll take those and you know
I'll stack them up in the Q a function
and zoom or in your chat uh in the
streaming service
see if we can get those all queued up
for the Q a we'll be talking about
business analysis careers we'll be
talking about what this program from
Purdue University offers
and how it gets your job ready Ryan will
take you through
a demonstration of the learning
environment so you'll get a feel for how
the learning actually happens and then
we'll go through enrollment steps for
people who are interested
let's get started
um Brian I'm going to let you introduce
yourself
um because you can do it better than I
do okay well uh greetings everyone
exciting to have so many folks joining
us from around the world so a little bit
about myself
um as Stuart said I actually uh work
very closely in this industry space over
25 years working in program project
management so you can probably expect
business analysis there's a really
critical part of successfully delivering
projects and programs I'm also very
involved in agile Transformations so the
last uh seven eight years I've been
really focused on helping organizations
transition from more traditional
practices project management practices
into agile practices again business
analysis is really integral to that I'll
probably get a chance to chat a little
bit about that later I work closely
simply learn so a lot of the content
that you see in the project management
and agile spaces is content that I've
been involved in authoring and working
with simply learn on some certification
exam preps I also work closely with
bodies like a project management
Institute agile Alliance
um working on defining techniques
practices and certification mechanisms
to help validate the the learning of
people that are interested in extending
their careers into those areas I have my
own company Seven Seas Consulting and I
didn't see it in our chat list Stuart
but uh I'm from Houston Texas I might
perhaps be the only one on the session
from uh from Houston it seems
welcome and howdy sorry
um
so let's you know chat about business
careers business analysis careers
um and I'd like to preface this by
pointing out the business analysis
is more essential than ever because
there's more data than ever
um
pandemic especially highlighted that and
accelerated the digital transformation
that had been going on for many years
things in our personal lives and our
business lives and our work lives have
been moving on to the web and onto
mobile devices but when the pandemic hit
and we were all told either to work from
home or to non-contact methods of
transacting business
much of that
digital transformation went into high
gear and one of my favorite
stories from the pandemic
came from the American fast food chain
Wendy's
which developed a mobile app so that
they could speed up non-contact
food ordering and delivery to let
customers order their food through their
mobile device
before coming to the drive-through
window and picking up the food
what they found out was that
they that created a new stream of
marketing information about the
customers their behaviors and
preferences that they were then able to
analyze and turn into new marketing
campaigns so
um this shift is is really highlighted
the need for people who can do that and
is that what you've been seeing over the
last few years Brian
yeah there's no question Stuart that um
we've got this explosion data
um there's information coming at us and
organizations from so many different
places but becomes really important
though is interpreting that analyzing
that and this is where the role of a
business analysis analyst is so
important and just as you pointed out
um you know organizations like Wendy's
and many others are you know
increasingly opening up mobile ordering
mechanisms and it's helping to get a
better understanding of who the
customers are where they are what
they're they're buying and purchasing
needs are so again it's business
analysts who are helping interpret that
information position these organizations
to move into New Market areas and really
capitalize on all this Rich data they're
getting access to yeah and and the data
is only useful if it turns into
uh business insights and that's the job
of the business analyst right so
um business analysts for business
analysis career you need to understand
of course
what business and requirements analysis
is but you need
these other skills can you kind of run
us through these and how they work into
the it's a career area absolutely you
know one of the things that I think
makes this particular area so
interesting is it touches on a wide
range of different types of skills so as
of course a business analyst you're
going to need to be close to data as you
just pointed out you're going to have to
have analytical skills to interpret that
but in addition uh this role often Works
closely with project management and
program management uh scrum agile teams
to really plan and monitor progress
around successful delivery oftentimes
because a lot of organizations are
moving into new markets they want to
understand interpret this data it's
highly strategic so many times business
analysts are working closely with senior
Executives and leaders oftentimes even
CEOs are asking them questions about how
can we interpret this information what
information do we have access to that
can help us grow our products and expand
our markets solution evaluation one of
the things that's uh I've always found a
little exciting about this particular
role
to get a chance to really kind of craft
what the right solution is based on the
data and the analysis that you're
performing of course A lot of times
dashboards data visualization becomes so
critical to interpreting large volumes
of data I do a lot of work in the
healthcare domain and just as you were
pointing out earlier they're getting so
much new information from all sorts of
different sources everything from web
portals where customers are coming in to
get Healthcare Services to hospitals and
doctors offices with information about
patients coming bringing that together
visualizing this in a meaningful way
crafting dashboards both for the
organization and for customers so once
you're in the space you're going to be
working closely with those kind of
techniques
um you may have heard me mentioned agile
scrum most organizations are making this
switch to more agile practices a
business analyst working in this space
is going to be you know really important
to interpret requirements that teams can
deliver in short increments of delivery
so data statistical analysis and then
you hit on something I think is really
important to your digital transformation
almost every organization even
pre-pandemic but the pandemic really
accelerated this has recognized that
we've got to get as digital as we can
so business analysis is often really
instrumental in helping organizations
make that transition
thank you yeah
um I've been working
in areas of digital transformation for
actually several decades but it was only
with the admin of the internet and then
with newer Technologies in the cloud
especially that
it really was able to extend beyond just
networked computers into
software as a service and things like
that that transform our lives so the
demand is really soaring because of that
and you're we're looking at statistics
um right now data the iiba uh business
analysis Association
says that there are
14.2 million people on LinkedIn whose
titles are business analysts or senior
business analysts
staggering number
um that's worldwide of course
um but
data Quest projects that the number is
going to increase by 25 over the next 70
years so that's millions of new analysts
who need to be uh recruited and employed
that handled this flood of data that
keeps Rising
you know companies nearly every company
assistance in this area but
here's a few Apple Microsoft American
Express Samsung Amazon these are
just a few of the top companies uh
currently on this is where got these
names from who are out there recruiting
actively for
for business analysts sorry didn't mean
to move backward
um
so it's a it's a huge and growing field
and
this is worldwide two of our primary
audiences for simply learning are in
India and the United States and you
could be
as we saw earlier we have folks here
from all over the world so you can check
with your local sources about what the
salary ranges are but
fairly strong
well-paying field and
uh upper end
that you can aspire to it's very good
and this is within business analysis
if you
go outside of business a business
analyst career and use your business
analytics skills
to build a general management career
move into other areas then
it becomes a springboard to even greater
opportunities for you so
um we're very excited about
how this can help people and this is I
think one of the reasons why as we said
at the title of the program you really
should consider a career in this field
um
in 2023 because the
growth potential is just that great
so you're all here because of that what
has stopped you up until this point
from seeking certification as a business
analyst for those of you who've looked
at
programs like this
and
not decided to go forward why is that
is it because you can't find a program
that covers all the skills that Brian
spoke of is it because you
don't believe you'd end up with
practical experience you could
demonstrate
to Future employers
because you don't think the methodology
for those programs worked for you or is
it because of finding time in your
schedule
I'm just going to leave this open for
another five seconds
four three
two one hit that submit button
and
primary concerns for our audience today
are
feeling that they'd want to have
practical experience to be able to
demonstrate the new skills
the end of the program and then also
want a program that fits into their work
schedule so that they don't have to
interrupt work to be able to do this
education and then strong behind that is
the
need for comprehensive curriculum
I didn't do this already I'm sharing the
results with the people on Zoom
you can see that
so let me
introduce the program itself the
professional certificate program in
business analysis from Purdue University
delivered by simply learn
is accredited by The International
Institute of business analysis
um it's a six-month intensive program
and it has a comprehensive curriculum
which Brian and I will describe to you
it's aligned to Industry needs for
Purdue University
Works closely with recruiting companies
and they yep feedback on what it is
those companies are looking for in
potential new hires what skill sets they
need so the curriculum is aligned to
those uh industry needs it features a
fully online delivery and Ryan will show
you the platform but you in the platform
you get live virtual classrooms so that
you can
interact with your instructors
ask them questions get your questions
answered
um
answer their questions of you during the
exercises the lessons and also interact
with your peers and then in between the
live classes you have 24x7 access to
that same platform do your case studies
to do your projects do all of the work
in between Class sessions
to prepare for the next class and move
on to the next 10 hours a week
um
on average and over that six-month
period most people can find that within
their
work in life schedule so
the end of the pro process you will
receive
certificates for different
courses you receive of course the master
certificate for completing the entire
program along the way you earn
certificates for the component courses
including some that are delivered by IBM
and you will do a number of Hands-On
projects in lab one of the projects is
the final Capstone project right can you
comment on the importance of the
Capstone project we'll get to it again
later but you just give a brief
notion of what that is yeah I know it's
a great question and in fact I think
this ties back to some of the uh poll
responses where you know folks who are
interested in understanding how can I
get some more practical experience that
demonstrate that I have these business
analysis skills so that's really the
intent of the Capstone project
um at the very end of all the program
we're going to bring that together
leveraging this Capstone project so that
term sort of you know speaks to the back
that sits at the very top of our our
learning experience and we are going to
draw upon all the skills that we've
developed and we're going to apply them
to a number of different real world
challenges that organizations are facing
large Marquee companies that you'll be
already familiar with and you're gonna
get to pick from a couple of these that
you can pursue and you're going to craft
a business analysis response to that
problem that opportunity that has been
to find and you're going to pull upon
again all these different skills and
techniques
um it's a it's a you know pretty big
project but you're going to be supported
by your instructors and your simular and
uh coaching and with that when you're
finished you're going to have a really
good example of how you can apply these
skills that you can show to your
existing employer maybe other
prospective employers and really
demonstrate that you've got skills that
they're looking for
excellent
um
along with those things during the six
months you have access to master classes
with Purdue instructors and with other
industry experts that we bring in
and for six months after you complete
the program we'll have a career assist
program available
for some of you who are in
U.S and India
um
and that some of those Services apply
worldwide a couple of them only apply in
those countries well I'll describe those
in more detail in a minute
Purdue University is for those of you
who don't know is a 150 year old
institution it is one of the top public
universities in the US it's one of the
top
universities in the world and it has
produced Nobel Prize winners and winners
of other
academic prizes
um it has developed
a number of Technologies over the years
heavily oriented towards engineering and
analytical methods
and
we talked about you get access to
certificate master classes access to the
Alumni Association when you've completed
the having Purdue University on your
resume on your CV is going to be
something that people will recognize
and take note of
I'm going to mention the job assist
so two parts of this the first two free
access to expert webinars
and the real world projects across
Industries are part of this program
worldwide
and everyone gets access to those
the job assist services
specifically apply in us and India which
include access to exclusive job portals
and
one of the biggest advantages of those
is that they allow you to do a job
search without revealing that on a
public portal like indeed or
dice or Glassdoor
um
they all we also including those both
resume review and rewrite and one-on-one
interview prep resume review and
rewrites very important because
resumes today go through automated
systems and AI bot will look at it
before any human does so you need to
have a resume written
to be compatible with that process it
also still has to look good and
attractive to the human eye when it
lands on someone's desk or screen so
balancing those two objectives is an art
form that a professional writer will
help you with and then the one-on-one
interview service allows you to work
with real human beings to practice your
interviewing skills and get coaching
because as we know that any Job searches
tells multiple levels of interviews from
the phone screen with HR or recruiter to
uh
technical interviews with your peers
prospective peers and manager who are
going to ask about your new skills and
then
management fit interviews that talk
about
your cultural fit with the organization
or work ethic your ability to be a team
player and each of those interviews
requires you to display a different side
of yourself
practices
very very helpful
so as I mentioned the webinars which
simply learned conducts are free
accessible to you lifelong and they
cover a number of different topics
throughout the month
the
topics can be overviews of Industry
sectors like business analysis or data
science that can be specific classes in
one hour mini lessons as particular
skills
they can be
job search advice or they can be
General
life skills and career skills advice so
all of those are available to you
and
of course there's the
projects that you'll be working on so as
Brian mentioned Brian you had said these
are companies whose names you recognize
and bring in these
case studies and challenges
for example for the Mayo Clinic one of
the world's leading Healthcare
organizations Hospital management system
design
um
that will look across all of the
information and provide it in a
dashboard to the managers
things like Amazon looking at a
particular business problem or
providing strategic advice to
CEO or BP of product management I should
say at Pearson
um or a practical application of
preparing a
canteen ordering system so these are all
the kinds of challenges that people work
on
this
these are the kinds of things that
people might choose for a Capstone
project
that correct
right exactly yep these are the four
different domains that you can choose
from so you can see that they are not
just um you know very well recognized
industry leaders but you can see they're
focusing on Spaces like
um Healthcare Supply Chain management uh
learning management and even food
management so all these different
sectors
um leverage business analysis so you
might be in uh something like these uh
domains or something similar so you get
some options to pick the one that's
going to be most relevant to the the
direction you want to go in your career
right and there'll be a number of other
projects that you do along the way each
course requiring
uh projects as part of the completion
Criterion to move on we'll talk about
the curriculum in a minute but for this
program you must have a bachelor's
degree 50 or higher marks which would be
a GPA of 2.0 or above
um and you must have two years of work
experience
so this is for working professionals
um not targeted at people just earning
their bachelor's or people who are still
working on their bachelor's and we'll
ask about that in a minute but you do
not have to come from an analytics or
programming background
um because the program will give you the
foundations you need for for those
skills
but let me ask that question
people in the audience
what is your level of experience are you
still in
school right now are you early in your
career within the first couple years or
are you more seasoned
I'll leave this open for another five
seconds
four three two
one
here are the results
so our audience is if I use my weak eyes
to see about 40 percent of you have
over three years of experience up and
um
about a
quarter of the audience are people in
the first couple of years of their uh
work life it might be a little early for
you for the folks who are still in
school
um
you'll want to wait until you've got
your degree in a couple of years under
your belt before you uh try to enroll in
this particular program
but we'll move on from here
we'll talk about
the people that you're going to learn
with
this
am I looking at this here we go
and apologize learn outcomes should come
later in this thing we I want to look at
the
curriculum and how this program helps
you so this is the important
information for right now
the program builds in a series of
modules each module containing different
courses
and
um
you must go through this in a particular
sequence that you
build the foundation from each course
for the next following one so the
induction session teaches you how to use
The Learning Management platform
set your expectations for the time
you're going to spend what each course's
curriculum will involve and what the
requirements are for passing to the next
course
um Brian if you want to go through the
this
stair stack with the Capstone as you
said at the top
yeah absolutely and then we're also
going to show you learning management
platform itself to get to some better
visibility to uh to the the actual uh
tools you'll be leveraging but uh yeah
so one thing to be aware of is is this
starts with an induction session so the
whole program is centered around this
idea of a cohort and a cohort is a group
of Learners all starting at the same
time and why that becomes really helpful
because it allows you to kind of share
some experiences to build some
relationships uh one of the things that
that's often isn't spoken enough about
but success in your career is often
driven by your network so having a
strong network of peers that have
similar interests and career aspirations
can be incredibly valuable so we'll
start with the induction session clearly
lay out the path that you'll be
following and then really get down to
business so the first thing we want to
ensure that everyone has a really strong
foundation with is the business analysis
professional
um Concepts and techniques so we're
going to spend time getting more
comfortable with really this
foundational level of understanding then
you're going to see we're going to
continue to progress upwards we're going
to shift into leveraging business
analytics with tools like Excel
as well as Tableau training
so you're going to get a chance to
really learn the skills on required for
the tools and then apply them to some of
these projects and and real world
experiences that Stuart mentioned
earlier and then we'll bring that to
close with the Capstone project that you
saw now a few things just bring your
attention you'll notice on the right
hand side there's a series of electives
so these are the additional course
topics that you'll get a chance to pull
from and you can see there's a really
wide range we've got Purdue academic
master classes what does that mean it
means you're going to be taught by
Leading experts in the space from this
highly accredited institution Purdue
University we're also going to have
industry master classes held by people
like myself and others who are bringing
real world practical experiences into
your educational journey and then you'll
see there's a whole collection of other
uh courses that you'll have access to
data science using are sort of a
statistical analytical programming
language we've got digital
transformation courses for leaders you
heard Stewart mentioned that one of the
exciting parts of being a business
analyst is it's actually kind of a
Gateway into other roles within
organizations increasingly uh leaders
within organizations need to have a
strong Foundation of business analytics
skills so you see there's a digital
transformation course for leaders
because many people taking these courses
end up shifting into that kind of role
and organization
agile scrum Master rules this is where
we're going to learn a lot about these
agile practices and techniques and how
to apply them
delivering products and solutions we've
got power bi this is another powerful
business Analytics tool uh similar to
Tableau SQL training SQL is another
language that you're going to develop
that's going to help you craft queries
to pull data so you can perform analysis
so you see this is a very rich set of
skills so you're going to get a chance
to develop and you've got a lot of voice
in which path you follow
and one thing to point out about the
electives is that they're all included
in the price of the program so you get
to choose as many or as few as you uh
are interested in and have the time to
to to do but we encourage you to take
advantage of as many as possible
um
talk about the different tools
and Tablo B in power bi we mentioned are
you saw on the list so a lot of
different
tools that you will use in each of the
course modules
not just be exposed to the names and the
user guides but you'll be required to
apply these tools and Frameworks to the
work that you do to the courses up to
and including the Capstone so at the end
of the process when you put these names
into your skills section of your resume
you'll have actual practical examples to
show to prove that you're confident in
each of these areas
and
just touch again on the Capstone project
because Brian gave a really great
description of that earlier how you pick
an industry challenge something that
would be what you would work on as a
working business analyst and you design
and Implement that solution to that
challenge with the mentorship of your
instructors you meet weekly with them
over a three to four week period and
create your personal project that gets
evaluated for your certificate but it
also is something that you take away in
your portfolio
demonstrate your your set of skills to
potential new employers or to your
current employer
that gives you real practical experience
to show off
so at this point like Brian to give us a
walk through of the learning management
system
be so kindness to share your screen
Brian you can betcha and please let me
know if you can see this
yep good awesome yeah so uh I know for
many of you you're interested in saying
seeing it a little bit more uh I guess
behind the curtains on on really what uh
The Learning Management platform looks
like and a few things let me just call
your attention first off you know having
been in in the place that many of you
are in right now you're interested in uh
finding a program that's going to fit
your interests your career directions
um so that's an important starting point
you really have to ask that question is
this a direction I'm interested in
investing in in business analysis
but the second thing that becomes really
important is you need first off to get
this certification this education from a
well-recognized institution there are
lots of different providers that are
available certainly globally
um employers are going to actively be
looking for right well recognized
institutions Purdue this 150 year old
institution a global leader in many of
these areas you heard uh Stuart talk
about the Nobel Prize winners that have
come from Purdue so Purdue is sort of a
well-recognized uh institution to get
these sort of patients from Simply learn
another one that is a global Powerhouse
in this space of adult learning so
that's a great place to start you know
you've got a these two Institute
institutions working together to ensure
that what you're going to learn is going
to be something that employers are
interested in in leveraging
the next thing is the Learning
Management platform itself so what are
some things you should be looking for
and I've worked with many organizations
I'm very familiar with this space
frankly you want some of the things that
you already look for when you're picking
your favorite you know music streaming
service you want it to be relatively
easy right you want a nice interface
easy to navigate something you can
leverage from any number of devices
whether it's your laptop your your
tablet your mobile device so what I
really like about this is the the
product this the way it's laid out very
intuitive it's easy to find what you're
looking for here we've got our business
analytics boot camp we're going to dig
into this a little bit right off the bat
you've got the courses that are core to
the completion of this this will be
available to you now recognize I'm
looking at one uh that's for our
instructors this cohort hasn't been
activated yet so you might see some of
the the messages being a little little
bit different when you log in but you
can see each of the different courses
here right off the bat we've got
introduction to data analytics this is
that foundational course we click on
that and what do we have we've got it
right off the get-go we've got uh video
learning available to you so it's like
you have access to a online instructor 7
by 24 whenever you need it it's going to
be accessible you're going to see a nice
collection of different well-structured
course lessons available to you that you
can progress through and go back and
revisit if necessary all of this is very
highly produced simply learn has really
invested in making that learning
experience as positive as possible so
you know whether this is something
you're doing perhaps on your lunch break
while you're working or when you're
waiting for one of your kids to finish
yeah you know one of their practices you
can do this on your mobile devices you
can set aside time to to really kind of
dive deep into some of these topics all
those options are available you'll
notice it tracks your progress okay so I
just started this uh we're at two
percent and you can track that to
completion we've got things like
assessments little tests to validate
that you've learned the knowledge within
the course material and there's
references little ebooks some of us you
know like to times print out reference
material that's going to be available to
you you can print that out take whatever
notes you need to and then finally of
course you can track your progress with
certificates that you can earn once
you've completed taking your course
material so this is an example of the
interface hopefully you're seeing it's
very intuitive easy to use we've got our
core courses we've got our electives hey
is where we dig a bit deeper into
perhaps different tools like python
maybe there's a particular problem
domains like some of the mathematical
optimization Solutions available that
you want to learn more about power bi
we've got master classes and both from
Purdue itself as well as from industry
experts so all that's available to you
here one easy to access Place one other
thing to bring to your attention is that
you know I mentioned you join as part of
a cohort so how do you connect with your
peers well we've got Community Options
available to you you can connect into
these actively monitored forums
available just to your cohort so you can
share you know experiences ask questions
some of your colleagues in the program
can help engage and support you or
instructors will be monitoring this and
are simply learned teams to ensure that
you're getting real-time support for any
questions or Clarity that you might
require
so a little flavor of that Stuart
anything else you think we need to take
a peek at together
no
um I think you covered it we do of
course have the 24x7 help desk I just
want to remind people of that so that in
addition to your community
uh you can raise tickets about the
operation of the platform or ask a
subject matter questions on an emergency
basis but the the community and the
other
tools for support really make sure that
if you're working at three o'clock in
the morning on a project for your
class coming up on the weekend that you
don't get stuck in a block or a dead end
that you have somebody to help you with
that so that's a that I think I think
covers it
um thank you very much for that yeah
shoot that I'm going to go ahead
and return to
presentation
I want to mention as you see here Brian
is one of the main room advisors
that works with uh Purdue University
with Dr
is the academic
bear with me I will be back in a minute
Zoom is
and by the way I do see folks are
posting questions in a q a that's great
uh thank you for taking time to do that
um
so if you've got a question you'd like
us to spend a little time on please pop
it in there I've been trying to respond
to a few of them myself so we can
hopefully get your questions answered as
as they're coming up but it looks like
lots of good questions emerging there
are you back with us Stuart yeah I am
the uh
Zoom platform I'm on does this to me
occasionally when we especially when we
switch from
oh screen sharing so
um but as I mentioned Dr Zhu is the uh
Purdue
overseer of the program he provides
Direction uh and alignment of the
curriculum with Purdue's corporate
partners
um and Jeff and Brian you've
direction to the
program
content and now is the time for learner
outcomes
do I not have here we are
we have santosh's information here
hold on for a moment while I share that
with you
going to
I started walking
hold on a moment
this should be an embedded video but
it's not so I'm going to
from
Southern application
again the screen sharing
again the screen sharing but hold on a
moment well I
share this with you
this is an experience from one of our
learners
I wanted to move into a technical job
profile but not in the software
development field
so after a lot of consideration and
research I chose business analysis as
the next destination in the professional
gym I am proud to say that I've cracked
another job at Comcast that I'll be
earning free
and percentage more than what I was
earning at Amazon
[Music]
I have done the post graduation program
in business analysis with code
University from Simply learning I took
this course when I was in the second
year of my business operations associate
job in retrospect I should have done it
sooner as my life changed for the better
as a result
offer from
flipping reports where I am currently
working as a business analyst
and proud to say that I've cracked
another job at Comcast where I will be
joining as a business analyst shortlist
that I'll be earning 354 percentage more
than what I was earning at Amazon so
basically in a span of 10 months I have
increased my income by 354 percentage
which I'm happy and excited about
my journey would simply Learned was
amazing retainers were experts in their
respective Fields whatever the daughters
was quite simple to understand and
straightforward even though I was fairly
new to this film it was great to be able
to learn on the weekends as well as to
after all clearing sessions
even before starting of course I had
access to all the training modules and
everything seemed very easy
so the technical stuffs and also the
tools were very clear who loves to
simpler
to motivate themselves and to accept the
reality one cannot grow until is willing
to grow you need to take action rather
than just keep procrastinating so take
the first step today and keep learning
all right
and
second as we go on to our next
a portfolio is a collection of work or
acid
so
pull quote from what you just saw with
Santosh
you can't grow until you're willing to
grow so the sooner you get started with
something that is going to change your
career path and your life
the better
um I'm going to share this poll with you
to ask based on what Brian
and I and Santosh have just shared with
you
um excuse me wrong poll
are you interested
in potentially joining the program
so I'm just going to leave this open for
another 10 seconds
5 4 3 2 1.
so
95 percent of people responding said
that they would be interested which is
great
let's move on I'm going to
switch out something here real quick
I'll be
right back with this
well Stuart you're doing that just let
folks know I've been uh responding to
some of the Q a questions so if you
posted a question there you might want
to take a look at there I did notice
that uh a lot of the questions might be
uh answers that folks have put into
other questions so uh uh but look at the
answered area and you can you can see
answers to questions you might have
asked okay let's go through the
enrollment steps for those of you who
are interested uh you start by emailing
us and ask us at simplylearn.net
and with that you'll contact our
learning Consultants who will take you
through uh the process they'll help you
verify your
um
academic experience your
show that you have the degree that's
required and also the work experience
that's required so
once that's there and they've evaluated
your
qualifications you will get an admission
offer
and
the next cohort starts with classes in
May
next induction session is the 27th of
April so you have a little bit of time
um before it starts but you want to get
your application in right away
the reason we say this is even though
this is a digitally delivered program
that doesn't it's different from
massively online self-study programs
this is done with live classes that can
only accommodate a certain number of
people so our cohorts are limited to
about 25 to 30
Learners and that means that you want to
get your application in if you want to
get into this cohort and
email us at ask us at simplylearn.net if
you're
interested in the price of the program
we've given the pricing here for both
India and the United States in the US
it's 299 dollars which you can Finance
over time at 264 a month in India it's
one lock eight thousand rupee which you
can finance an equal monthly
installments of 35.85
rupee per month and again email us to
get started
and
I want to ask now when would you be
interested
starting this program
your
and we'll just leave this open for
another five seconds because it's a
pretty straightforward question
four three
two one
and
so
well over half our audience almost 60
percent are interested in getting
started either in the May classes or
maybe June July right after
and we encourage you to get in touch
with us and ask us to simplylearn.net
um for those of you looking further down
the road including people who are still
in school and not ready to start the
program do contact us and ask us at
simplylearn.net we'll be able to keep in
touch with you over time and inform with
you about future cohorts of this program
I'll discuss options with you so
I think I would encourage everybody to
get in touch with us for that
and
moving on
this is where Brian and I will take your
questions
hopefully stopping sharing will
avoid the
horrible zoom problem that's having
but I'm going to take a look here and
Brian you you can see the questions in
the Q a yeah we had a couple uh that I
quickly answered one question you know
it came out a couple times do we need
technical uh software development coding
experience take these courses the short
answer is no
um we you know it certainly helps it's
not going to get in the way of you being
successful but if you don't have a
technical background
um these skills are going to be taught
to you through the courses and the
entire program itself
okay dubious
for business and analyst career
opportunities is it better to do an MBA
in finance first and then business
analytics training
or would you do it in the other
direction
yeah so if we think about it so an MBA
is a pretty big investment of time I
have one myself uh they take where
upwards of two years if you want to do
it on sort of a you know uh online uh
Pace it's probably going to take you
longer so it's a big investment of time
now that's a very well recognized
Master's level course I personally might
recommend this might be a better
investment you're going to get this in
six months time real world applications
some skills you can immediately take
into your existing work environment or
use to get to maybe that that better job
opportunity that we heard in one of the
testimonials right and with the
foundation of the work that you do after
becoming a business analyst through a
program like this
you give yourself a better foundation
for success in an MBA program because
yeah you'll have an understanding of the
applications
um uh these skills in the business
principles to take into the MBA program
with you so it's always helpful
um
let me look through here if I am not
India or USA can I use the resume help
and one-on-one interview over Zoom
um Conrad unfortunately we don't offer
that outside of the um
those two countries right now but
we may be doing in future as as progress
but um
yeah over Zoom would be the way that
services are provided because we do
everything digitally so contact our
learning consultants and they ask about
the options for that because that
that's a great question
again it's simply learn operates in over
150 countries it's something that we're
always
very conscious of
at least two years of work experience is
required
even not a program here that's an
observation about you so that's correct
and we had another question from someone
in Cameroon who asked about the job
assistance program so again contact our
learning Consultants about that
um
okay
looking for a question
I know a little hard to sit through some
of them okay uh so here Colin asks a
great question which is I've been
studying data science on my own using R
how is that different from what we would
do in this course hmm
yeah and on the face of it there might
not be much difference uh so it's it's
great that you've already shown some of
that initiative and and even spending
time with this
um you know we will be teaching some of
the fundamentals you might already be
pretty familiar with those if you've
been doing this independently uh so
maybe that just gives you a little leg
up on that particular course offering
but to again remember these are going to
be taught by experts so you might have
some some questions that you've
uncovered in your own Learning Journey
and this would be a great place to ask
those questions to someone who's really
deep into R and I'm confident you will
also be learning lots of exciting new
ways to use our through this course so I
think you're in a great position take of
course I'm impressed that you've already
shown that initiative uh but I'm pretty
confident you'll be discovering a lot
more than what you already know
and of course the the program covers
much more than the our programming data
analysis skills so I'll introduce you to
other sets of tools including Tableau
for visualization
um Power bi and
it'll also give you some of the
uh
theoretical background or the
fundamentals and principles around
analysis digital transformation the
other aspects as well as the
Brand's particular subjects of agile and
scrum and
uh all of this is taught
Brian said with live instruction
as well as
video courses that you prep with between
the live classes as well as
a platform that you can do all of these
different projects and exercises on
so you don't have to invest in
additional software or
additional Hardware in order to do that
it's all provided for you on the
platform
with a virtual machine that you use to
do your project and that
gives you more in-depth
program and more well-rounded program so
Paula I hope that that answers your
question
is this entry level or is there a prior
skill set required so the answer is yes
and no there's no prior skill set
required but you do have to have
the bachelor's degree in work experience
so it's not strictly entry level but the
entry level
requirements aren't based on having a
particular prior skill set
um
what if you don't have a ba but have
industry experience
you need to ask our learning Consultants
whether exceptions can be made on that
basis are
Purdue University sets these
requirements and so
I can't
give you a definitive answer on that the
learning Consultants can tell you what
the industry
University's policy is
and
looking through
is the experience needed required in the
business analysis field only
um
and for someone with less than a year of
experience you wouldn't qualify so I can
tell that no you don't have to have the
experience in the business analysis
field it can be any work experience
your exposure to real world work
experience in any field in any capacity
gives you an idea of how
business works and what the needs in
business are for
analytics
however the
one year
experience might be a blocker for you
you should again contact our
learning consultant it may be that other
experience that you have you may have
more work experience than you
are imagining because you may have had
prior work experience in your life that
would qualify as well so do check with
us
um
how can you access the recorded video
for this particular session we will be
sending out a follow-up email with a
link to this recording so you'll be able
to review this material
uh
what other job options will you have
after completion of this course apart
from business analysis
that's a great question because
business analysis is a set of skills
that you'll be able to use in a lot of
different fields is that right right oh
yes no doubt about it in fact uh one of
the things that makes business analysis
particularly powerful is the fact it's
very transferable across Industries and
organizations and different parts of an
organization different roles
um and this is why again I kind of
described as a little bit of a Gateway
it's a Gateway into other roles and
opportunities throughout an organization
right
um someone in the UK asks if they can
apply yes this is open to to Learners
worldwide
um doing statistics is this help a BS in
statistics is this helpfulness program
and yes absolutely
um we don't require your bachelor's to
be in a particular field but data
science and analytics is based on
statistical principles so definitely
this is uh this is helpful especially
since it's you also say you've learned
some of our programming so that's
perfectly
perfectly app uh apt for this program
um
so we have an attendee who has been
looking at different um
courses to help develop their career and
they're seeming a little frustrated
showing their lawyers that they need
that they are able to move up I think
one of the things we can say about this
program is it gives you a
a broader
range and a portfolio of experience that
you'll be able to show off
so that you have more proof behind your
claims of your ability to do
bigger and better work for your
organization
grow professionally
um
we also offer of course depending if you
are in the uh
us or UK we offer those
additional job assist benefits and that
will also help you so
I encourage you to ask our our folks
uh ask us at simplylearn.net
so that covers to the bottom of our Q
and A I'm going to take a quick scan
through the chat to see if we have
questions that
come up
pardon me for that
I think
at the wrong place now here I was
looking at the Q a again
for a moment
okay
I am not
picking out the questions from the
stream so
yeah I think we might have covered
mostly I think we've covered pretty much
most of it if we have not covered your
question please reach out to ask us at
simplylearn.net and
learning Consultants will be able to
help you with additional questions
and
we had a compliment from somebody about
the webinar so I appreciate that
from that I'm we're going to move on to
the last question for our audience
and hopefully Zoom will allow me to do
this properly
this last poll question is pretty
straightforward
do you want us to reach out to you if uh
if you answer yes to this question we
will also send you
a proof of attendance for this
particular webinar
um which doesn't have much professional
value but if you need it to show
that you have been
attentive to your career
we'll be glad to send you the proof of
attendance
is this open otherwise answer yes if you
want us to reach out to you and help you
with any questions or get you enrolled
I'll end the poll in three two one
and sixty percent of you would like us
to reach out so we will do that
said
emailing you after this session so
expect that within a couple of days
at this point I'd like to say thank you
I'm going to put into the chat also the
link to the
program home page
and that will allow you to
take a look at the
program syllabus and other information
about programs so
that now is in the chat
it's also the QR code that you see on
the screen
and of course ask us at simplylearn.net
to contact our learning Consultants
I want to thank Brian for being so
generous with this time and his
expertise today
thank you Brian my pleasure it's great
to spend some time with everyone and
yourself included Stuart thank you
and I want to thank everyone in our
audiences both on streaming and here on
Zoom for joining us and wherever you are
in the world
noted some of the locations
from places ranging from Washington DC
to Mongolia and parts in between and so
we're very grateful that you are here
interested in this program we hope we
can welcome you into the Learning
Community with Purdue University and
simply learn
and with that I'm going to end the
webinar
okay thanks everyone